everyone's okay and then it starts to
get a little right and then you know it
got worse I got worse on that one so
we're both confit lovers and we've
always wanted to learn how to make latte
art so today we're headed down to
Stumptown coffee roasters in New York
City to learn how I'm Susie Locklear I
work for Stumptown coffee roasters and
I've been a barista for over eight years
now the plan is to teach you guys some
latte art there are a couple of
fundamental things that go into making a
beautiful latte so today I'm going to
teach you how to pour a heart into a
latte which is a fundamental design to
start out sort of your latte art journey
and not entails just keeping your cup
nice and tilted you're gonna pour that
milk into that deep pool of espresso and
then you come down not moving very much
but the heart sort of blooms into your
cup so we're gonna go through the steps
about so just go ahead and pour the milk
into the pitcher right below that line
I'm filling this up so there are two
main parts of steaming milk stretching
the milk which is introducing air which
is that sound that you hear that sound
and that's what takes your cold sort of
flat milk and turns it into nice creamy
texture lock angle and then grab your
the milk pitcher and give it a nice spin
because milk separates by density so the
foam is gonna float to the top
and then the the liquid is gonna seat to
the bottom filter cup here pitcher
distance right for the center oh that's
terrible
that doesn't even look like a heart
beautiful set that down on the counter
oh yay so that's beautiful you have a
nice contrast
great job Maggie you did really well on
your first try so now you're gonna go
solo
we're in try again nice nope it got
worse and got worse on that one so we've
made an improvement from the last one
right because you actually can see a
little you see it
so we tried our best but I think we
should leave this up to the
professionals can you
show us some of your other designs yeah
let's do it so first I'm going to do a
tulip that's what I'm the best at it's
my tried-and-true design so you can't
have good latte art without good coffee
because you need crema to float your
milk on top of and you also can't have
latte art without well steamed milk so
they kind of work in conjunction with
one another to make you know your
beautiful latte next I'm gonna do a
heart what really drew me to coffee was
the collaborative nature of it coffees
handpicked by one person it passed
through a ton of hands before it
actually gets barista and that sort of
just harbors a lot of community at
harbors connection between people the
last design I'm going to pour is the
Rosetta which is my nemesis because
there's sort of two sides of the brain
tulip and Rosetta it just calls on
different skills so the most important
thing that I tell Brisas about latte art
is that it doesn't taste like anything
it's half of the equation but people eat
with their eyes so you have to have well
steamed milk
well extracted espresso and a love for
the craft to kind of have the whole
package it's really good special thanks
to some town coffee for having us
[Music]
[Music]